[Musique]
est-ce que nous sommes connectés
alors je ne vous parle pas de la
connexion informatique mais de la
connexion à un de nos sens le regard la
connexion visuel alors certains parmi
vous diront que cette connexion visuel
est parfois mise à mal de nos joueurs et
pourtant elle est le préalable le
préalable au vivre ensemble
alors pour découvrir cette connexion
visuel je vous propose un voyage un
voyage dans le monde du théâtre
la collection visuel dans le monde du
théâtre s'appelle le regard public et ce
regard public a beaucoup évolué au
niveau des siècles le théâtre à
vingt-cinq siècles et pendant 21 siècle
le comédien s'est efforcé de regarder
son public pour le convaincre de son
propos alors c'était vrai chez chez les
grecs par les amphithéâtres ensuite sur
les parvis des églises et enfin dans la
rue et c'est seulement au xviie siècle
que le théâtre s'est retrouvé dans les
boîtes noires que l'on connaît
actuellement
c'est le philosophe diderot qui est
l'instigateur de ce que l'on nomme
encore actuellement le quatrième mur le
quatrième heure est un mur imaginaire
entre les spectateurs et le comédien
alors comment se se matérialise ce
quatrième mur déjà par une scène
surélevée à une distance respectable du
public
et puis surtout par des lumières sur
scène le comédien et éclairer le public
lui est dans la pénombre voir le noir
absolu alors le message est clair un
pauvre public regardez le comédien
pour le comédien le message est
également clair un ne tient pas compte
du public de toute façon tu ne peux pas
le voir avec les éclairages alors fait
comme s'il n'était pas là voire même tu
peux jouer de dos 1
alors c'est un choix artistique un choix
de nos connexions toutes les formes de
théâtre n'ont pas fait ce choix par
exemple jeu masqué a fait le choix de
briser ce quatrième mur de rentrer en
contact avec le public et de faire des
réactions du public la source du jeu
ouais bon ça [ __ ] qu'est ce que j'en
sais rien
le masque ne regarde pas le public
uniquement avec les yeux mais également
avec le nez pour tourner son corps
entièrement vers le public pour une
meilleure écoute et une meilleure
transmission
alors est-ce qu'il suffit de regarder
avec le nez pour rentrer en connexion je
vous propose de continuer le voyage avec
le plus petit masque du monde
le masque de clown un clown regarde le
public avec le nez mais il faut qu'il
fasse une chose pour m face à un public
c'est ouvrir les yeux
peter brook un grand metteur en scène et
surtout un grand pédagogue de théâtre
avait l'habitude de dire que le comédien
doit être un enfant expérimenté il doit
retrouver son âme d'enfant ce tout en
ayant l'expérience de l'adulte la prise
de recul et bien ouvrir les yeux s'est
retrouvé le tram d'enfance s'est
retrouvé notre capacité de curiosité
d'émerveillement c'est très facile pour
le l'enfant ça l'est beaucoup moins pour
l'adulte qui a une tendance tout naturel
a retrouvé son côté expérience briser le
quatrième mur
regardez avec le nez ouvrir les yeux ben
je vous propose de l'expérimenté non
puisque nous allons pouvoir participer à
notre première pause
alors avant de vous rejoindre
il faut quand même que je vous fasse un
aveu je détestais les pauses et les
cocktails
alors il faut savoir que pour un ancien
grand timide comme moi devenu maintenant
aux réserves et l'expérience du cocktail
est vraiment difficile
alors on voit bien tout le monde est à
l'aise 1
alors nous timide on ne l'est pas du
tout alors on essaye de se connecter
alors on se donner une contenance
oui au bois une flûte on mangera coup et
puis on se connecte non pas visuellement
mais un autre portable
le doudou du 21e siècle
alors on demande me demande souvent
comment se fait-il qu'un grand timide
puisse faire du théâtre puisse faire des
conférences puisse faire des formations
allez je veux faire une grande
confidences les grands timides adore la
scène
parce que depuis le 17ème siècle et
l'avènement au des lumières quand un
grand timide et sur scène vous êtes
obligé de l'écouter
contrairement aux cocktails où on peut
passer inaperçu et la deuxième chose que
l'on travaille lorsqu'on est sur scène
c'est la connexion visuel alors je vous
avoue les grands timides me comprennent
au début c'est très difficile parce que
d'avoir tous ces regards sur vous la
main franchement on n'est pas habitué
aux départs dans la peur et puis avec
l'expérience il y a une sensation très
étrange qu'apparaît une sensation
difficilement descriptible mais une
sensation où on a l'impression que ce
n'est plus le public qui nous regardent
mais nous qui regardons le public
alors évidemment ça donne une sensation
de contrôler voire un plaisir certains
diront même une certaine jouissance
alors est-ce qu'on devient moins timide
pour ça eh bien non mais notre timidité
se transforme dans une espèce de réserve
une réserve qui est assumée qui nous
dérange absolument pas un et qui
n'empêche absolument pas la connexion
visuel alors pour terminer notre voyage
dans le monde du théâtre
je voudrais partager une dernière
réflexion avec vous un sujet récurrent
dans les familles c'est l'importance du
temps passé par nos jeunes générations
devant les écrans
alors certains disent que c'est pas des
outils aussi maléfique que ça ça
permette de travailler leur créativité
et leur activité certains disent que
c'est le cours de l'histoire
en tout cas
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
il manque quelque chose et ce qui manque
c'est de la connexion visuel alors les
parents que nous sommes nous sommes
lancés dans une bataille une bataille
pour limiter l'utilisation des écrans
parce que l'adversaire a des arguments
son portable lui sert aussi à écouter de
la musique son portable ils servent
aussi à prendre les photos seins c'est
bien d'avoir des photos de ses séjours à
l'école son portable lui servent aussi à
nous téléphoner
oui ça peut servir aussi à ça alors je
sais pas si c'est votre cas
mais sincèrement moi je suis pas
submergés par les appels de mes enfants
alors je voudrais entrevoir avec vous
une dernière stratégie une stratégie où
notre énergie notre créativité et
sûrement notre autorité ne serait plus
fixé uniquement sur la limitation des
écrans mais inciter nos jeunes
générations à pratiquer une activité où
la connexion visuel est importante et si
il accroche parce que vous avez des gens
des gens des artistes des enseignants
des animateurs qui font un boulot
formidable pour faire en sorte que vos
gamins accroche à une activité et s'il
accroche
il va prendre confiance dans cette
connexion il va prendre plaisir à cette
connexion
il va en prendre aussi du temps en
oublier parfois il a un portable et bien
je vais vous faire un dernier aveu la
pratique théâtrale a été pour moi un
formidable outil de connexion visuel et
c'est pour ça que le sens de ma vie
professionnelle
aujourd'hui et depuis 20 ans ceux de
faire partager cette pratique de la
connexion dans les théâtres pour que le
théâtre
retrouve son essence de connexion avec
le public et surtout en dehors du
théâtre dans la vraie vie la vraie vie
dans les écoles dans les universités
dans les entreprises est mon plus beau
cadeau
mon plus beau cadeau c'est quand un
individu jeunes ou moins jeunes passent
de la pénombre voire parfois du noir
absolu à la lumière parfois le chemin
est court et parfois il est long alors
on l'accompagné
et quand il est dans la lumière il
commence à s'ouvrir et c'est à ce moment
là que je comprends la phrase de jean
cocteau
le regard est le miroir de l'âme
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]